Oh
my deck can come stay here it's me
battle of the bin full one the
undefeated four loko are looking to
bring the champagne tonight but before
they can get their tabs on the Pimm's
Cup they'll have to go through juice if
you be from mezcal tag you know he's
gonna get blitz tonight the rookie gets
his shot to prove himself after their
top show QB was suspended for texting
photos of his cocktail skies a river
clear the club seats are filled and the
cans are going wild here's the kickoff
and it's a highball we must protect
children from the severe and deadly
consequences of drinks like for local
and juice and some of the other ones due
to regulatory difficulties buzz bowl
will not be seen tonight please enjoy
this special FDA acceptable presentation
already in progress and ever since this
caffeine heist flick and iced Marco has
traveled the world from California
trendiest bars to the Australian outback
simply because it offers a two-in-one
combination of things that late-night
revelers love caffeine and alcohol the
making a superior Irish Coffee is a crop